welcome cmake
tutorial i've lost trouble on nine
libraries part two find package this
whole thing right here
that's what we're gonna mainly talk
about today here in this example i'm
going to be finding glue
because it's not well maintained for
windows at least not for the visual
studio
compiler so it's kind of annoying so
i will say right off if you want to use
glue on windows
you either got to go download the
binaries and use them directly
or you need to use a different compiler
other than the visual studio compiler
for the example let's start with the
find library i'm going to expand on find
library a little bit real quick
and then i'll get into fine package and
i'm also going to do it on windows and
linux so i'm going to jump around a
little bit but hopefully this helps you
develop a good understanding of fine
library because i basically have spent
way more time than i thought i would
trying to figure all this out and
mostly because i was going back and
forth between platforms i was like let's
try it on windows now that'll be fine
ah well i will go over everything i
learned and
teach you how to become an expert
or maybe not an expert but you know way
better than you probably were before
since you're watching this video
glue so if you just google glue you get
this site bluesourceforge.net
and you can get the binaries for windows
32 and 64.
and the latest version as you can see it
hasn't been updated since
since 2017. so if you're using using
glue
don't use something else use glad or
something
this is no longer maintained basically
mainly because it's like specific to
opengl and opengl was no longer
maintained so
but you can still go get the binary so i
went and got the binaries
and i'll show you how i did it here with
the find library
i put it in development libraries glue
and then this is what it extracts as
when you get those binaries you get the
bin which is like the dlls
yeah the dlls and you get the live which
is the
linker libraries that you need when
you're building
and the include directory for glue so
but finally this does not work with the
find package though
because find package needs a
config.cmake
and those binaries do not come with it
if you go to
if you download the latest source and
try to build it with visual studio
it doesn't work it's not configured you
have to use an old version of visual
studio
so it's no good but with those binaries
you can still get it to work by
by just pointing to it and you do have
to manually put it in here with paths
as you see i've mainly put it in a path
then i had to put in some suffixes
for to check down those paths
under live release 64 and also down this
we're good alright so real quick on the
fine library just to wrap this up if you
want to use glue like we've been doing
before i know a lot of people still try
to use glue
you do the same things we talked about
last time but now you have to actually
put in the paths to it
so that's my path to the root of it and
then i have some suffixes it for it to
check when it's looking for things
and uh very good and then when you link
it later it says required
you could do this whole check thing make
it fail if it doesn't otherwise you
append the list
so that should make sense to you
same thing we did before but now we're
just adding
uh here right here to our pin list that
we're going to append
at the end uh extra livers extra
included
you've probably figured out by now that
you can do it different ways
like since we know it's definitely found
here we could just go ahead
and say target
link library glue
live that points to the library
and target
include directory
i guess you know you have to know where
it is and put it in there
so that's a little unfortunate because
that means if someone's downloading it
just goes down here if someone's
downloading it they're gonna have to
manually do some of this stuff and
that that stinks because you want people
to just be able to clone your software
if they're working on it well if it's
closed source and just work on it you
don't want to
have to make them figure out a bunch of
stuff so that's basically the point of
this
is in a way where people don't have to
figure out a bunch of stuff
just use your software they can just hit
the clone button open it in
in something as long as they've got
cmake it'll work
and of course maybe a few other small
requirements but
you don't want to have to get a bunch of
specific dependencies
and make it all confusing for them and
so that's what find library ends up
being in this case
okay so let's talk about find package
we're just going to delete all
this this is going to be gone the
dependencies are part of the project
like if you've copied them into your
project
and they come with it then you don't
need to do any of this fine library
stuff you can just directly
link to it and that'll be fine
but these are more modular because
well they will find it from specific
spots
all right so let's talk about this fine
package a little bit
so when you use find package you put in
the name of the library
and whether it's required or not there's
a whole bunch of other options
if it's required you don't need to check
if it's found because it's gonna
it's gonna stop here glue if glue is
found if it got here so you don't need
to do required
but if you don't do required you can do
some kind of check
and say something happens
or something doesn't happen like else
if here that's the only other case so
you could do a little switch around if
it's not required to maybe use the
library or not use the library or
implement some of the earlier things
about
the options of using and linking or not
linking
because sometimes libraries are optional
to do special stuff
but in this case we're mainly going to
look at whether it's required now
there's some more things about this that
are a little peculiar and i'll explain
them as i go
one of the big things is you're going to
either do this as a module
like so you just put module here or the
default is module
but it also there is config
and if you do it as a config it needs a
cmake some kind of config
for the library so for example i'll show
you that with
glue so i went to github and downloaded
the glue source code
and what it looked like was
like so let's see glue here's glue
and here's what their repo looks like i
think i messed with this home so it
might be a little different but
they have a build cmake
and a glue config.cmake right there so
that's what it needs to know about
that's what it needs to point to
if you're doing find package config
and you'll see like it doesn't do it
here with visual store with uh
yeah visual studio code it's not quite
smart enough
but if i open cmake for example
and i've run it on my project and path
to my project here and i'm path to
the build directory i'm going to go
ahead and delete the cache
and i hit configure let it do its thing
it's going to fail
and that's fine let it fail and then you
just got to fill out something
so if this fails and says doesn't find
the glue der
glue not found this is what needs to
point to that config
however like i mentioned it doesn't work
on windows just because the library is
out of date
but in general a library that you clone
and build will work
so i'll just show you for example google
glue here go to build
go to cmake or wait a second
or was that i guess it was cmake yeah
and hit configure again
and now it's happy sort of happy well
it's got some other problems
but it keeps this in here if it didn't
find it like if this directory was wrong
and you hit configure it'll clear back
out to not found it says not found
so if it switches to not found then it's
messed up
but it's invalid because it's not built
it needs to find
like all the stuff but i tried to build
it
like i hope i went to visual studio and
i opened this
the latest solution let's see open a
project or solution i looked at their
directions
they say basically
to go to
build and visual studio there's no vc16
so they haven't updated it for the
latest
version they say use this solution
and it has some errors when you do this
so not a whole lot you can do about that
so seems like if you're using glue you
just want to
do either the fine library or bring
those binaries into your project and use
them or just link to them directly
so fine package is not so great for glue
in this case but this works fine in
linux
because you could just sudo apt-get
install
live glue dev or whatever and
now this fine package will just work but
okay the difference between the can i
showed you what the config is now i
talked about modules so let's go back to
that so
when you say module it looks for
a a find module and what a find module
is well it looks in your cmake module
path so you got to set your cmake module
path
and this is a folder so it's a folder
right here so you make module path
and it looks for a file in in that
module path called
find the name of the library then dot
cmake and it has to be specifically that
capital f on find uh the exact name of
this package thing
and dot cmake so you could do this for
anything which is kind of cool
uh new files so you can say find
asdf.cma
and then in your main cmake you could do
a
let's see what a find package asdf
and it'll basically run this thing
and it expects you to set everything
this is where it expects you to do all
your work
but some of these are included a lot of
these
you don't need modules configs come with
with cmake so if you like look at the
cmake documentation
if i google search find glue c make and
just click one of these
you'll see that it's part of cmake and
there's find glut
there's fine there's a whole bunch of
fine basic libraries
and it tells you all about what it does
if it finds them
so you might need some other stuff
there's find git for example
so these are just valid commands as long
as you have a version that
supports it and so you can double check
here and make
sure someone mentioned this
documentation is not always up to date
but what are you gonna do it's the best
you got uh especially if you're using
like
an older version or something so
hopefully
that all makes sense but for example if
you look at find git it tells you
example usage and it tells you what it
imports
so
so if you do that on on this here and i
think actually we did do that on the
cmake modules yeah we do a fine package
get
earlier and that's essentially using
this same thing
so if we wanted to make our own version
of finding git we'd put a module in here
and we'd design our own with find
get dot cmake and then we could write
our own code
for where cmake is now i would recommend
just looking at
some example of these i don't want to
write one of these but
just know that you can do it and that's
what it does when it's
a module so it does default to module
and if it doesn't find a module then it
goes to config
so in general you just want to leave
this blank that way it checks if you
have a module
if you don't have one then it just uses
the default cmake
config which is whatever it has built in
to do it if you're using that config one
you want to look it up on here and see
what it does
so for example it gives us the get
executable
perfect and that's what we actually end
up using here
get executable right there
see that so we were actually already
using this i just didn't talk about it
before
uh so that get one it'll get you all the
stuff it sets all the stuff
and it just like with glue it tells you
what all it sets
so there's a couple variables you can
set you just do those with the set
and then this and then whatever you want
to set it to
um and it gives you the imported targets
like the shared libraries so if this
works
we could say we could use this as the
link library
and we could use all this stuff we have
the glue includers
the library shared libraries have a
found variable
we have the version so that's all what
it brings in
so all right and if you if you do put
module or config in here
it only does that one it doesn't do the
whole backup thing where it tries
config or tries module first and then
goes to config
you type one in it only does that one
package
let's just google this go to the top
document
and let's look at this real quick so
we're basically using the basic
signature module mode which is find
package
package name version you can leave that
blank and it'll just find whatever
version but if you know a specific
version you need you can put that in
there
and then you can have exact or not and
there's that quiet mode you can turn
you can have so basically these
bracketed things are optional
you can say module or config
on on that one you can say required and
also there's components
so i don't think i'm going to talk about
components but
you can read about it on this page if
you're curious then there's optional
components
and then there's a full signature mode
which has more options
and this is probably actually what we
would need to do
to get it to work properly for uh glue
on windows since we don't build it we
have to point to all the binary stuff
with hints and paths just like we did
with find library
and i'm now going to uh
remote connect to my linux machine
and here we are
so i've commented out all the old stuff
from the last video
and if we just put like for example
blue required
it will just work we'll get everything
of course we could do modules if we want
so i guess as to another point
a lot of libraries don't have that
config yet a lot of
libraries the whoever is developing
doesn't have a conf they don't have a
config
file in there in their code
but they should blue here
just using it as an example here it is
so it's down in build cmake there's that
so that's what you need to point to
with config for that if you're if you're
building it
but if you're not building it you don't
have to worry about that anything you
build
or have compiled on your own you're
going to have to do that
or all right so let's let's look at
another one
let's look up i don't know let's look up
glfw for example that's another one we
look at a lot that's commonly used
so this will also have a
see make config somewhere in here
probably
so if we time we search we'll find
config.cmake
and we should be able to find that
somewhere in i guess they don't
but let's see let's look at some boost
libraries
and let's look at see if within here we
can find a config.cma
don't think so
so uh not all libraries support this
this is uh
something that should be in libraries
but is not necessarily going to be there
so you might have to just write your own
find module so i don't know maybe
let's look at sdl uh
stl and i think of another library
they've got cmake in here
i don't know no these are not configs
yeah here we go big
it's a dot in though i'm not sure
exactly what this is but
this is basically it
yeah it'll see it just sets all the
libraries and sets all the
properties for the libraries so
basically this
when you use this module it just finds
it
and it sets it up for your project
please like comment subscribe it would
mean a lot to me
and please do just do it
just hit the buttons
trying to think what else i should add
here i guess nothing let's just
let's just build this i'm going to
delete
these sh files i don't think we need
them anymore
see what kind of error we get if any
let's do a build
hit play and it launches our window so
actually it actually works here
so our main is including glue and glut
i don't think we need glut all right so
the lfw3
has all the opengl stuff and glue is
just an extension wrangler to call the
opengl
stuff but uh with
this will include the headers for opengl
so that's why we don't need to include
gl so we could essentially
do something with
uh open gl here now at this point
we just had some code and i guess i you
know i could go find some
let me go find some real quick these
uh this shouldn't be glue libraries i
don't think
target link library should be glue
libraries
so since we weren't using any glue stuff
that's probably why it wasn't
uh having any problems
let's just do a little google foo
i found this gist i don't know if this
is good or not but
using glue and glf w3
let's just
[Music]
comment out all my previous code
i might put zoom back in but
let's just walk through this from the
top it includes glue and glfw
excellent and
we've got a print errors function
and we've got some defines for debug
stuff
and we're on release so we're not going
to be using those and our
editor has gone ahead and
uh grade those out so that's cool
another function here called print
shadow shader info log all right and we
got a main
so he declares a window initializes the
window
creates a window called hello world
makes the context current to that window
then does a glue a knit and make sure
glue is okay
and then let's see he does a he makes a
little a vertex shader here
and a fragment shader here just some
little basic ones there with the
position and a color
and uh then you declare some vertices
probably just a triangle
and some elements uh yeah just a little
triangle there
and then here we go here's a vertex
array object in an opengl stuff now
and he's using his check call function
up here
uh oh this is just seeing what it
returned basically
so it's mainly that's the actual
function he's just wrapping in a thing
that's
going to spit out what a one or a zero i
guess
or whatever returned basically something
like that
and he's binding it binding it uh
okay binding of vertex array object and
then a buffer
object for all the actual vertices
and an element buffer for these elements
here
or the indices and then he's going to go
ahead and
compiling the shaders so compiles the
vertex shader
files the fragment shader and then
combines him into a shader program
and he has a position attribute uh
for this shader
not sure exactly what this is but
do something with it uh is it part of
one of these shaders
yeah in in vector position yeah
so that's just uh where he's pushing up
everything
or how he's linking it to the shader so
to speak
then we go into a while loop for jlfw
wow we should close
and it looks like he's just going to
draw
and you know swap buffers pool events
dlfw things
and then if that exits he deletes
everything and terminates
so it looks like this should work i
think this will work fine
so we we're pretty close up here
actually we just basically needed a
glue in it here i'm not super familiar
with glue
and yeah and check for errors and then
basically we could do stuff
so that's essentially what this code
down here is doing
let's see if it'll run build
i think it will well this will tell us
if
blue is linked and included correctly
basically
well that's the whole problem is it's
just it's there's an error in this
yeah okay
yeah there we go let's try that
okay there we go
yeah there we go i guess i'll include
that with it just for the heck of it
yeah i'll just fix this up and commit it
that's going to be the video i hope this
makes sense with all this fine package
stuff and modules and not modules
been awful confusing to get a video
about
it i see why there are like none out
there because it's just so much to cover
that how many takes would this take to
get it right
a million i'm just gonna release this as
it is i'll try to edit it to make sense
please uh show some support thank you